بعد 12 ساعه اغلق باب التصويت للمرشحين
الانتخابات المجلس الامه الكويتي ليتم فرز
الاصوات واعلان النتائج حيث يفوز من كل
دائره عشره مرشحين بمقعد في قاعه عبد الله
سالم ناس خايفه بان تكون الاجراءات ايضا
خاطئه مره اخرى
لابد من المشاركه لان انا دائما اقول حق
الناخب يجب ان تشارك اذا سويت تحسن الوضع
انت جزء منه ان لم يتحسن فانت بريد ذمتك
لكن اذا ما سويت وظل الوضع سيء فانت جزء
من هذا الوضع السيء وجزء من المشكله لكن
اذا تحسن ساهمت في تحسنه اكثر من واحد
وخمسين في المئه نسبه الناخبات النساء حيث
تغلبنا على الناخبين الذكور عددا وتصويتا
بحسب القضاه في اللجان الاصليه والفرعيه
والمراقبين في الدوائر الخمس
بس شو نسوي هذا المسؤوليه لازم نقوم فيها
بديت اصوت لما صار عمري 21 سنه تقريبا صار
لهن تجريب الاربعين سنه يعني اصوت
الاختلاف هالسنه ما شاء الله ما قاعد اشوف
في زحمه يعني ما ادري يمكن الوقت الحين
لان الظهر بس اعتقد هي نفس الوجوه ونفس
البرامج ونفس كل شيء في الشارع الكويتي
للنتائج الانتخابات التي ترشح لها
اشخاص وتنافست فيها ثلاثه عشره امراه فقط
املا في الوصول لقبه عبد الله السالم من
الكويت شاهد المتروك العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات